Let's write out one way to do this together.
I will assign the return value to this variable next_states,
and then we'll just return next_states later on,
but this will make it a little easier for me to think about it.
The hint was definitely to do some sort of list comprehension over the rules in the grammar.
That's going to look something like this.
For every rule in the grammar put something in our output.
Well, if there was something like E goes to xyz in our grammar,
and we're bringing in the closure on E,
the state we want is really just E goes to the red dot is all the way to the left,
and everything that was the right-hand side of the rule comes to the right of the red dot.
Remember that we're encoding parse states as simple tuples.
The first part is this big nonterminal.
Well, that's just the 0th part of the grammar rule. That's just E over here.
Then the next part is what's before the red dot.
When we're computing the closure there's nothing before the red dot.
That's this white space right up here.
Then there's what comes after the red dot. Well, that's xyz.
That was just the second part of our grammar rule.
Then finally we need to know what the current state is.
For us, based on our definition of closure, and you can go back and take a look
if it has slipped your mind, that's just i--the state we're currently looking at.
When we're computing the closure, we add more information to the current chart state.
This is pretty much two-thirds of the answer.
The trick is there might be other rules in our grammar like T goes to abc,
and we don't want to bring them in.
We only wanted to compute this closure on E.
We're going to need a little guard here in our list comprehension.
I don't want to take every rule in the grammar and bring it in.
I only want to bring in some of them.
Well, what's the thing I'm supposed to be bringing in the closure for?
It's based on cd. Cd is whatever we saw to the right of the dot.
Remember that our current state is something like x goes to ab dot cd.
First I have to check if cd is not empty.
If it's not, then c is E, is the thing that we should be looking for.
I only want to do this if cd is not empty and if this E, which was rule 0,
matches the first part of cd.
That is if this E is the same as c.
If it is, we bring in the closure, and that's it.
This is one of those examples that really shows off the power of list comprehensions.
We want to take a bunch of grammar rules, slightly modify them into parsing states,
and we only want to do that based on the rules of how the closure is supposed to work.